well cuz you got two grown men having
wrestling that doesn't hurt now if you
want to go at it right now you said the
word you're working on my second stripe
on my white belt I'll watch that oh go
to his school you'll be a black been two
days on HBO crashing anymore purple ball
hey know I've heard that uh yeah heard
they move people along everything in
somebody's places no no I'm just kidding
not vegans vegans I have a good day guys
it was a hot ten but I feel like there's
a lot of guys in New York besides Andrew
Schultz who just took this social media
and [ __ ] YouTube like a banshee
a lot of Newark guys are like oh wait a
sec a lot of the knots to do you know
yeah is there an observation you have
about new cuz I don't know I feel like
the New York guys like all the New York
Comic like the comics comics all of them
are kind of like social media very new
yorky thing just look at a lot of
tickets I know when you have so great
like some of the greatest Davis house
one of the greatest there's ever great
yeah he's the best
seven he's for Olympic there's a genius
aspect yeah I know no I know there's
definitely younger guys Dan Soder mark
Normand Burgas yeah all like the big
boys over there but guy so he's like
yeah yeah I don't want to deal with this
I know you wonder what it was um not you
know New York though not a bit early on
so early on oh no it's not just from New
York it's that culture I remember early
on going into the Comedy Cellar and I
would check my clothes so that Patrice
Jim Norton and David tell couldn't
attack not David tell Colin Quinn
Patrice Jim Norton it like said we don't
know but they kept it in such a well
verily they would just look you up and
down be like you've shown your eyes are
too close together
Patrice will come I mean there would
always be you did well I didn't know him
that well but I know I'm well enough to
know that like anything you did that
felt like you were trying to sell some
so it's almost like if you think about
music in the 60s with nobody did
commercials and then you think about
music you know in the 80s or 90s or or
now especially it's not so bad to sort
of monetize certain things
was a culture I think where any time you
tried to push and market in a sense that
wasn't straight comedy they those guys
had a beef and I think there's a
residual aspect of that like you find
like Jim Norton he's been on raiveer
he's a cutie was basically doing
podcasting and it stand up and there's a
reason why Jim so big and Jim such a
good comedian Jim's great calm him was
one of the first one in New York who he
longs even doing radio phenomenal a long
time but they wouldn't see radio as
social media they would see radio as
radio yeah yeah oh yeah no no absolutely
the priests would have been a great
podcast no but listen there's a wait
look there's a way to do it it's not
going away if you're a core if you're a
horse-and-buggy builder you know and
Ford comes out at some point you gotta
go listen I've got to I've got to I've
got to incorporate the you were the
[ __ ] question engine you were the
[ __ ] guy the iPhone 5 was already out
six he calls Mary goes you know I got
this iPhone and then if you know but I
had an arrogance right I had a bit of an
arrogance and I also had a couple of
bucks and I was also really involved at
that point I had an opportunity to go
and build you know the the
capitalization on this project is 17
million dollars it's not all mine but
we're building a project really involved
in that the idea hold on hold on to
something that is sort of I didn't know
what it is that I'm who I'm talking to
or why I'm talking to them I do know now
and under Brian's tutelage oh wow from
Carrie the followers know to a lot more
bless still a very small amore does that
look like the moon the surface of the
Moon I don't look like a shar-pei man
look sharp an older man sharp a man it's
right know what hurts me as I go I'm 53
and people gum ok Michael but you
supposed to say aye have you ever asked
any girl what do you think I like it
like 40 yeah [ __ ] you man yeah yeah
I wear well dude yeah of all the
wrinkles though I don't you have you saw
the line in the middle here the line
here really look at my face I know
you do it but there's so many wrinkles
do yep they're all over bro they're all
over your forehead come on bro hold on
you guys [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this guy to
my left you guys are my friends hold on
folks us forehead hold on I look at my
hats unblemished face wrinkles
wipe your you see me for the first time
okay right see them first time focus on
the forehead go notice the big line down
the middle or you pointed out yeah let
me see my face for a second I'm gonna
take a picture and I want to take a look
what the [ __ ] is really gone those the
wrinkles you done with this [ __ ] do it
dude
I'll have more wrinkles when I'm your
age let me feel I can't see it sliding
Oh Bubba you don't know that
I used to have big wide eye I can see
mine anymore is it now you look like the
emoji that's all yeah my god I can't
permanent skeptical hippo it's more like
Pat Sajak bring him up he got his lids
done this is what you dis is a ditty
yeah but this is not what you want cuz
some guys get brow lifts you can't get a
brow the Wheel of Fortune yeah yeah you
can't get a brow lift you see what's
going on with his eyes oh no can't do
that you can't do that she was happening
to he had his brows lifted and you for
whatever reason you go hmm something's
off he looks evil now he's an old man
dude how much work has [ __ ] mrs. Vandy
a bright eyes like that you can't have
as a man having bright eyes see how his
eyes are all bright Kenny Rogers bring
him up they all look like wax ring up
Kenny before and after Kenny Rogers
before
hey so someone sent me a meme of you
because this is count after you get his
lids done and it was the Chucky Cheese
doll there you go see that's the other
problem
see what it looks like he's got his face
tightened and he had he gets talked into
having his face tightened there you go
no that's a it's tough man you're an old
man by the time you know man dude be an
old man gives a [ __ ] about you'll never
see that with me I'll just be an old man
we'll see I don't your eyes get Oh
another
half an inch lower and you gift you have
visors you have skin visor these [ __ ]
AIDS
leave me you have skin visors hanging
off the lid well now it's just time to
get it cuz it's not gonna be overly yeah
you're right you don't do it when you're
just I'll get it for you for your
birthday
okay I'm saying to Tijuana every every
plastic surgeon it's like lids are easy
do it in my office yeah until you come
and then he look [ __ ] yeah I know a
girl who had her lids done and one eye
smaller than the other she's like what
the [ __ ] huh and I didn't realize until
she told you walk and I go well they're
in the home so it's nice in the military
she's got sniper I gotta get em read I'm
like alright well you know I mean I
don't miss it one maybe just get the why
I just get the one all sniper I know
what I don't know I don't know if I'd
ever do anything to my face uh you don't
need it well not yet dude you probably I
don't see you getting I don't know
you're young we'll see where will your
big man though it doesn't matter when
you're a big giant I think you can just
have a big giant face you got thick skin
I wanna be tight yeah you just be a
[ __ ] giant a big giant face you're
gonna have you're gonna be a giant with
a agile dude I don't think you're gonna
die young I think you're gonna I think
you'll live till these [ __ ] but I see
now you live your live a while but your
give myself salt 70-72 it's gonna get
tricky these do it you always work out
you've been staying in shape and you eat
well
yeah cardio is the biggest I don't think
I don't know that that's sweating right
now yeah yeah my kidneys your to seven
yeah what ya know stuff one who knows
I'm sweating though bacon yeah big boy
just big your bully boy just big yeah
strength cuts through technique just
farting I did it yoga class with Jimmy
Burke and the woman next to me
well poorly poorly young lady not not so
young you know a woman who has just had
some weight and she was a hippie and she
started just claim
it's hard not to laugh like that and and
Jimmy goes Jimmy looks at me he goes
like this he goes dude you can't be
farting like that and blaming her video
my brother they act like it's just all
good
like they're in the safe zone it's like
[ __ ] it's a hundred degrees right next
to my buddy Jimmy pro football player
who are doing yogi never done your crew
before he's a sick athlete legs all must
go good-looking and we're in we're in
Venice and this beautiful her name is
Shiva Rea she's this [ __ ] phenomenal
sheet when she was younger she was so
hot and famous yogi she's teaching the
class and it's all these like like you
know it'll be oh yeah she leans over and
she's got a crazy ass right crazy ass
but she was younger she she was just so
hot like look there she's doing
something like that and Jimmy goes like
this to me goes he didn't mean to do it
so like he goes as was I think he goes
yes look at her oh no and then she rang
a bell got Sachin 20 years ago she would
break your back she was so hot yeah oh
yeah still as hot Shiva Rea she predicts
millions of dollars still oh yeah high
end high end demand
there's her ass ooh she up yeah cheeked
ups cheeked up and you know I'm not Yoda
but don't care but don't care I love you
like I'm young I eat well and I do yoga
I feel amazing you're 28 shut up you
could do anything I mean hanging out
arcade all your life and you could drink
and do blow all that ya feel great in
the morning after then after your first
coffee and then it started so we talked
about this guy before this is the guy
from fire festival that went viral
because he said that he was willing to
suck dick for the Evian water that's a
new release he actually just got a
sponsorship with Evian and they're
starting to release specifically made
bottles that says Evian so good you
would do anything for it
Wow
Wow so he's he's officially a
spokesperson for Evian hilarious it's
good on Evian for being funny that's my
favorite water you're right
bet on him before now for what he's
willing to do for a he's just a good
employee
she's a I was ready to got my knees no
he was prideful they needed water and he
had to go talk to the town council guy
oh he said whatever was the guy who was
okay in the water I said yeah I was
ready to get on my knees and to suck his
[ __ ] right yeah and because because the
guy goes if you I don't care if you have
to suck his [ __ ] and he goes well I was
gonna suck his [ __ ] for the water yeah
he was dead soldier that's a soldier so
if I move in with a guy I'm doing it for
water why is all this Evian stocking up
their friend right got 32 bottles of
Evian three guys on the couch what
happened I don't know I'm a big fan of
EV en hmm that's right